This video is made possible by VIN Sara watches,
luxury handcrafted watches at fair prices,
checkouts that black Friday sale this week of Inserra watches.com forward slash
biographic
And the Patheon of rock star decadence.
There's one name that showings brighter than all the others combined.
Freddie mercury was the man who did everything by extremes the lead singer of
queen. He possessed a personality bigger or a more flamboyant than even the BAMS
loudest songs. It was Freddy who threw the greatest party.
This side of ancient Rome in new Orleans in 1978.
It was Freddy who turned seduction into a high tempo art form rushing off stage
between songs to bed. Another beautiful man before rushing back on again. Yep.
This showmanship went beyond yeah, hedonism.
It was also Freddy who in 1985 played along evade said so bombastic it's
estimated to have got a staggering 40% of the world's population rocking along
with him. But while his lifestyle remains legendary,
there was another side to mercury. One far more complex than it is on the stage.
Persona would suggest born twinsie and policy parents.
Freddy was a perpetual outsider arriving in Britain in 1964 hands who operate in
a world in which both his ethnicity and sexuality locked him out as an alien.
This is the story of how that outsider went on to become perhaps the greatest
performer of all time.
Fruit bowl Sarna was born on September the fifth, 1946.
He couldn't have seemed more unlike the legendary rock star he'd one day become
the eldest son of two Parsi Indians,
a community of Zoroastrians who'd fled Persia to escape persecution.
His family had its roots in the Bombay of the British empire. Indeed,
the empire was an outsize influence on the family's life.
While his dad was a civil seven working for the British on the African Island.
Zanzibar,
thanks to this family were able to live a life of comparative luxury that home
in Zanzibar stone town came replete with servants into nanny to look after young
Farrukh,
the embar also influenced the boys' education while his parents were committed
Zoroastrians. They sent the boy to Zanzibar missionary school,
where he was taught by Anglican nuns.
It was at the school that the boy was nicknamed Bucky on account of his
overbite. Yes, this mild physical defects, which turn out to be a secret power.
Many years later when his Faruq personality had been left behind Freddie mercury
would refuse to get his teeth fixed,
less doing so destroyed is incredible for Oxford range. When he turned eight,
the boy left Sam's the bar center.
Now independent India to study at an English style boarding school.
It was during his years, that two important things happened.
The first was that Bulsara discovered he was utterly obsessed with music onto
the watch for live his grandparents in nearby Bombay. He formed his first band.
The second was something Bulsara never talked about much,
not even when he was famous.
It was a boarding school at age 14 that he had his first sexual experience with
another boy come 1963.
Bulsara had graduated and relocated to Zanzibar just as the Island one,
its independence from Britain. By now,
the Charles had big name of Bucky was gone replaced by the much less cruel
nickname. Freddie back on the islands,
Freddie Bulsara divided his time between finishing his education and swimming in
stone towns, clear waters. It was a fairly aimless existence. One befitting,
a teenager who didn't yet know where he wanted to be or what she wanted to do.
This is a good Freddy have known. The decision was about to be made for him.
The Zanzibar revolution exploded in January of 1964,
pitting the African majority against the ruling Arab elites and it killed
upwards of 17,000 people.
The ball SAR has fled the violence using British possible itself into the
family. When both India and Zanzibar exited the empire,
this was how Freddy Bulsara lost. Came to settle in England. In 1966,
he was doing a design course in London and feeling confident about a career in
fashion.
It became commonplace to see Freddie strutting along portabello road dressed as
a pirate say, or working in a clothing store, link Kensington in full leather.
Even at this early age,
she possessed a white hot streak of self-confidence telling anyone he met that
he was going to be a star,
even though the bands he was now playing with were milk toast.
Best that confidence still rubbed off on people.
When Freddy strengthened into the cult fashion store Bieber in 1969,
his attitude flawed sales girl, Mary Austin,
the two began dating and within months they were living together in a cramped
apartment, but it would be two other people.
Bill Saraj met around this time who changed his life.
One was a mobi astrophysicist, the other, and Lethario studying to be a dentist.
Their names were Brian May and Roger tanked up along with Freddy.
They would soon form the band that would make them all famous.
[Inaudible].
Since you were watching a biography of Freddie mercury rock God,
rather than Freddie mercury random dude who did nothing.
You already know how the band is going to pan out, but it's worth pointing out.
Just watching an unlikely prospect queen seemed in the early seventies,
how divisive people found them. One music, journalist memorably, put it queen,
or either the future of rock and roll or a bunch of raving poofters.
The thing was nobody could really tell queen had formed in 1970 the same year
for root ball Syrah legally changed his name to Freddie mercury.
There was a change that Asha did a new public persona.
One more outrageous than ever before.
As Roger Taylor said it was Freddy who instilled in us,
the belief that we had to make people gossip every time and making people
gospel was something queen excelled at on the stage.
Freddie was already wearing Maskcara.
Codpieces leotards already exhibiting his incredible showmanship for a lot of
audiences.
It was too much queen West slated in the music press with Freddy himself,
singled out for harsh treatments. Yet this criticism never seemed to land.
Instead. Freddie deflected it with winking.
Self-deprecation like when he declared of queen,
we have more in common with Liza Minnelli than led Zepplin. At the same time,
the band was solely finding its footing in 1971 basis.
John deacon joins completing the classic queen lineup in 1973,
the group released debut album imaginatively titled queen off the back of this.
They've got a gig playing support for Mott the Hoople UK tour.
Despite this being a major step hop,
Freddie was outraged that he hasn't been given a tour of his own being support
is one of the most traumatic experiences of my life. He half joked in private,
still,
it was hard to complain by Windsor queen were playing their first foreign tours
and while ends up writing their second album,
the even more imaginatively titled queen to,
or they tried and records were barely paying them. A living wage.
Freddie still felt secure enough to propose to Mary Austin,
not long after the band score, their first top 10 hit with seven seas of ride.
So things were looking good as queen headed off to that first American tour in
April, 1974. Again, supporting Mott the Hoople,
but sometimes looks can be deceiving rather than their big breakthrough Queen's
America tour became a horror show when Brian May contracted hepatitis and the
whole thing had to be canceled as the Greek pretend to Britain on an emergency
flight.
It's easy to imagine how despairing that long trip over the Atlantic could have
been bus. If there was anyone who could overcome despair through sheer force of
personality alone,
it was Freddie mercury that summer queen returned to the recording beef for
months ready, works like a demon possessed by some volcanic drive,
working to turn the bands ailing fortunes around,
and this he succeeded sheer heart attack landed like a glitter bomb in November,
1974.
It was the album that introduced the world to the queen sounds to that bombastic
mix of opera high camp and heavy rock as mercury declared.
We found our identity now and we have the feeling we can outdo anyone,
but while sheer heart attack would save the bands commercially,
it wouldn't be the album that cemented that place in music history.
No that all know would go to a single that mercury was now just a year away from
writing a song that has been interpreted in as many different ways as the second
amendment. Freddie would call that song, the Hemion Rhapsody,
and it would be his final breakthrough and to superstardom.
And if you're looking to break through into a stylish superstardom of your own,
consider paying a visit to the awesome black Friday sale of today's video's
bonzer VIN samurai finding a wash that is stylish, bold,
built to last can be pensive proposition,
but then Sarah is changing that and I want you to look good regardless of your
budget. I'll watch.
It should be something that you look forward to putting on every day when Sarah
was dedicated to the craft,
they put the time and effort into crafting time pieces that you can wear
every day, day after day. That's why they have over
25,005 star reviews because you won't find a better made watch for this price.
Now the watch I'm wearing right now is a recent one.
I've got actually it's been Sarah's automatic watch. Let me just take off,
take this off so you guys can take it. I need to take off,
but I would describe that as well, secured and on the bank. You'll see,
it's got a transparent case back so you can see the mechanism and sign the
watch. No need to ever change the material. Yes, this is automatic.
It just automatically winds on your wrist and it looks great on the front too.
I've also got another one here. Now this is a chronograph model.
So if you just hit the top button here,
the chronograph handles start to move around the watch face.
And so you can keep time of things hit this bottom one, boom,
and it goes back to center. Also a great looking watch. Look,
this holiday season of Inserra watch makes the perfect gift.
Well you'll self or a loved one starting on November.
The 19th of Inserra is holding a massive two weeks cyber Monday sale with 15%
off everything on their sites. That means sunglasses, bracelets, wallets,
and of course watches as well. You don't need any sort of special code.
You don't need a referral link.
Anybody visits the site where they get that discounts and also discounts up to
25% and as always,
shipping is free 30 day return policy and there's a two year warranty.
So what are you waiting for? Use the link in the description below.
Take advantage of [inaudible] biggest discounts and you'll receive up to 25%
off. Let's get back to the video.
[Inaudible].
The lead up to Bahamian Rhapsody's release was outwardly one of success for
Freddie mercury and queen Shehata Zack.
It turns them into serious players transforming their earnings from a
Dickensian.
Pitons do Scrooge McDuck style volts of cash over night. Yeah,
it's behind the scenes.
Things were significantly less rosy there's 1975 war on Freddy and Mary Austen's
relationship began to fray. Although they still nominally live together.
Freddie was spending more and more time away, only returning late at night.
If he returned to do old Austin thought he was having an affair with another
woman and she was half right. A fiance was having an affair only,
not with a woman. David mins was Mercury's first serious boyfriends.
Although their relationship didn't last.
It was a transformative event for the singer.
Even while the two were sleeping together,
Freddie began experimenting with gay hookups.
It was like a switch had been flipped. Mercury had never been monogamous.
So juicing plenty of women, even while he and Mary Austin were engaged,
but often mins, the singer's tastes shifted as Brian May later recalled.
It was fairly obvious when the visitors to Freddie's dressing rooms,
daunted to change from hot chicks to hot men.
And there was suddenly a lot of hot men around Freddie mercury, beautiful boys,
sort of from all over the world. As a result of this transformation,
it's been suggested by a whole lot of people that Bahamian Rhapsody was written
as a secret coming out song.
Now we don't want to read too much into what may just be a pleasing six minutes
of a Pratik nonsense,
but it's not hard to see how Mercury's in a life might have been reflected in
his masterpiece.
Things finally came to a head with Mary Austin in 1976 with Bahamian ramps at
the end it's parents album night at the opera by now a smash success.
Freddie mercury sat down with Austin in quiet holding tones.
He told her that he thought he was bisexual. According to Austin,
she responded by saying no Freddie. And I think you all bisexual.
I think you are gay today.
This looks like both by Eurasia and well playing wrong.
Although he showed a real preference for dudes.
Freddie would have significant sexual relationships women well into the 1980s,
but it wasn't with Mary Austin anymore. Austin moved out shortly after,
although she and Freddy would remain close friends later,
Freddie would tell people that she was essentially his wife still Boston's
leaving.
Seems to have been the catalyst for Freddie embracing his sexual identity.
He began appearing in clothing that mimicked gay,
bisexual and subcultures in 1978. Don't stop me. Now.
He cheekily sang about making both the supersonic woman and supersonic man out
of you, perhaps in knowing knowledge to his own preferences. Yes,
even as queen turned up the camp, two 11,
even as Freddie began dressing in public as a Castro clone,
he never publicly discussed a sexuality, asked by a journalist to say once.
And for all,
if he was straight gay or BI Freddie simply gave a toothy grin and replied,
I sleep with men, women caps, you name it,
but while his public persona would never make a definitive statement one way or
the other, his private life would tell its own often lurid story.
[Inaudible].
The 1970s. We years of eye watering access as queen shows got bigger and more
choreographed.
So did Freddy's hedonism fund became something created with precision drugs were
flown specially into cities to be on hand.
Whenever the single wanted to snort gorgeous men were captains steady supplying
Freddie's Liberty inside even appears during shows with it becoming standard
practice firms,
rung backstage between songs to be sexually serviced and then returns a belt
out. The next number,
the outrageous high point of this probably came on Halloween 1978 to celebrate
the launch of jazz.
Freddy rented the Fairmont hotel in new Orleans and through an eye wateringly
expensive bash to rival anything in ancient Rome,
transgender dwarves were hard to offer guests cocaine that was specially flown
in from Bolivia erotic dancers,
suspended from cages vying for attention with naked waitresses while gigantic
nude womens, sprawled elegantly across tables, lighting cigarettes,
glowing and multiple orifices,
beautiful models of both sexes wrestled in a pool of rural liver,
fiber eaters and drag Queens competed for space with a man biting the heads off
live chickens in the expensive model.
Toilets prostitutes of both sexes offered their services for free guns.
Of course, everywhere. As far as the,
I could see where mountains and mountains of drugs, it was mercury.
In a nutshell, a Pratik bonkers brilliance campaigns, not Alyssa perverted.
It was also everything his detractors hated about him already perceived as all
style and no substance Queens.
Overwrought accesses turns them into critical whipping boys bread.
He was delighted whenever critics, but the question to him,
he retorted all true darling where the most preposterous band that's ever lived.
And then on assumes he stuck his nose right back into a handy bag of uncle
Escobar's finest while queen as a whole earns a reputation for access.
It was really Freddie mercury,
who was the mad shooting star burning through the sky is at 200 degrees
Fahrenheit in 1980. This thing settles in a luxury apartment in New York city,
almost every night. It had a trendy clubs, the dues,
as many people as he good and funnel them back to his apartment.
When he woke up at 4:00 PM, the next day,
there might be hoards of gorgeous young men who needed to be chased away before
the madness could begin a fresh. It was a crazy time even by rockstar levels.
And it also seemed to be freeing. Finally,
mercury was becoming the icon has perhaps always dreamed of being the
uninhibited by sexual music.
God has young self could hardly DataMagine sadly this freedom wouldn't last.
And at least September of 1982,
Freddie mercury turns up at a New York doctor's office complaining of a weird
white spot on his tongue. Today.
We know it was likely an early sign of the HIV infection probably picked up that
summer.
But back then AIDS was only just starting to seep into the public consciousness.
In fact, the name AIDS was still a couple of weeks away from being coined,
but while their men's no sudden outing in the press,
no stigma attached to Mercury's name. It also meant something else,
no cure for the rest of his life.
Freddie Mercury's body would be slowly eaten away by the disease.
It hadn't even known existed.
That disease he wouldn't even be officially diagnosed with until 1987
tragically. His days were already numbered.
If you were to.
Queens fortunes across the 1980s,
they would resemble one of those jagged sham prize graphs with the arrow
shooting wildly up and down on the one hand,
the band scored its biggest single yet with on depression,
sometimes known to delusional wide rappers as ice, ice, baby.
They also cracked South America playing what was then Brazil's biggest of a rock
concert.
On the other hand is that U S sales took a battering as Freddy's Quinn as became
more overt before falling through the floor.
When the band appeared in drag for that video, I want to break free.
At the same time,
tensions backstage were resulting in fist fights between members,
including one at an Italian festival that turned into a full on brawl.
But perhaps than the deer came in 1984,
when queen played South Africa at the time Nelson Mandela was still in prison in
the world was boycotting the apartheid regime into this queen steps.
Do you play eight nights at a whites only entertainment complex?
The resulting Fure nearly killed their reputation queen were handed a massive
fine by the musicians union and were professionally ostracized. Yes,
this stupid self-inflicted low would be followed by the bands and Freddy's
greatest high. In 1995, the band received a call from Bob.
Geldof asking them to play a 20 minutes set for live aid concert,
designed to raise money.
If a famine relief in Ethiopia broadcast to 110 countries with global viewer
numbers reaching 1.9 billion live aid was simply the biggest concert in history.
Everyone from the beach boys distinct to David Bowie was playing. Yes,
it would be queen that stole the show. Unlike some of the other artists,
Freddy knew this was performance on a grandiose scale.
That 20 minutes would be the hits and nothing more.
And Freddy was going to give it as a today.
Queens live aid set is a metric with a showmanship.
Probably never seemed since Nike re electrifying the crowd, his energy,
his passion was practically stupid human it's estimated that at one it's not
just 40% of the global population tuned in to rock along with them as career
peaks go. This was a variable Everest that same year.
Freddy also had a new high in his personal life in March.
He met Irish hairdresser at Jim Houghton have a gay club in London.
Originally Huston was just another conquest,
but after a few weeks of fooling around, how did untold Freddy?
It would have to choose between keeping him or keeping up his Lethario ways.
Incredibly Freddie chose Hutton for two would be together until the end of
Freddie's life and short Freddie mercury in 1985 had everything,
the respect of the world,
a steady non-volatile relationship and more money than he could ever
realistically spend.
But this was sadly just a temporary high that very next year,
the arrow would come plunging right back down to earth. By 1986,
it was clear that Freddie was seriously ill.
His parents became gone like a starving man.
Rumors began to swirl in the British press that he might've age.
The following year, two of his friends died from the virus.
Not long after a former manager turns boyfriends out of the singer to a British
tabloid already feeling hurt and betrayed. Freddy. Last bit,
the bullet around Easter, 1987,
he went for an HIV test and you already know what the results were.
At first mercury told only Jim Hutton retreated to his Kensington home and rally
ventured out in 1987,
there was only one possible outcome to a positive HIV test.
Death aged barely 40. Freddie was already living out his final year.
Yes.
Harry's final years were almost unbearably sad from a hedonistic rock. God.
He became a recluse only, ever venturing out to work in the recording studio.
Still, at least he wasn't alone.
Jim Hutton remained by his side becoming almost as much as carer as his lover.
Mary Austin too, was still around.
She spent as much time with Freddie as possible in those final years,
still the only person the singer felt he could really relate to. Yes,
even as he was dying, Freddie still retained his acid tongue.
If he thought Queen's music would last, he Reilly responded.
I didn't give it dare. I wouldn't be around to worry about it.
The end came in November, 1991 on the 23rd of that month.
Mercury at last released a statement confirming to the world that he had AIDS.
Well, maybe it's unfair to say Freddy released. According to Jim Hutton,
mercury spent his last days on earth dose stop to his eyeballs on morphine
drifting in and out of consciousness.
It had been a deliberate decision to keep his diagnosis a secret until it no
longer made a difference.
Freddie mercury died the next day of bronchial pneumonia aged only 45
Hutton still playing the role of carer was changing the stars close as he passed
away. And he later said, while I was putting his boxes on, I knew had gone.
I went into my bedroom and stopped a carriage clock.
Freddie had given to me the time it was 12 minutes to seven.
When the news broke,
hundreds of fans turned up outside the home to pay their respects.
There was talk of a grand funeral final party.
It isn't that Curry off into the heavens,
but Freddie mercury had already died perhaps months earlier. In those last days,
fruit Besara had been all that remains and he wants to do a small traditional
sorrow stream. Funeral Reddy's body was cremated on November the 27th, 1991,
along with the bulk of his estate.
He left his ashes to Mary Austin who agreed to scatter them some West secret the
location she chose remains unknown to this day in the wake of Freddy's death.
Bahamian Rhapsody was rereleased in Britain where it shot to the top of the
charts or royalties went to the Terrence Higgins trust UK charity,
combating HIV and AIDS.
Yet this wasn't the end of Mercury's time in the charts before he died,
the singer had horridly recorded vocals. So several new songs,
which the other members of queen then set to music and release as a last hurrah
for a brief period in the 1990s,
it almost felt like Freddy or at least his ghost was back and just talented and
outrageous as ever today, nearly 30 years after his passing,
the legacy of Freddie mercury still lives on.
Even those you consider queen the epitome of style over substance acknowledge.
He was one of a kinds performer with an unbelievable vocal range.
He also remains legendary for his personal life since 1999,
by visibility day has been celebrated every September a month. Chosen,
purely being one Freddie mercury was born in. Yeah,
for all his influence in other areas,
it will always be his music that Freddy is best remembered for.
Here was a man of almost unbelievable talents.
A man with a voice that could sell quiet tragedy as easily as it could sell
operatic bombast in the ends, it was a talent.
This allowed him to live up to his own mission statement to become a star global
icon. There will likely never be another Freddie mercury,
but the music he left us is already enough to ensure his name lives on for
centuries. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do at that sums up button below.
Don't forget to check out in Sarah watches.
There is a link below and thank you for that.
[Inaudible].